vous savez il est de bon ton en ce
moment de faire des polémiques pour tous
et pour toutes les images et sur tout et
n'importe quoi et là il y en a une qui
vient de sortir c'est sûr nabila laïb il
a été à dubaï comme tout bon
influenceurs qui se respecte sont tous à
dubaï pour des questions de climat la
pluie c'est vrai bagage et des images
c'est au cours d'une soirée et laet a
été un peu à peu qu'elle est nous qui
nous regardent
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
alors est ce que vous êtes choqués ou
pas par cette polémique ou d'accord avec
cette polémique je suis choqué je sais
pas où est ce qu'on la passe et que vous
la comprenez adhérents non moi alors moi
je comprends le rayo désolé mais moi je
comprends ça fait partie de son
personnage ça fait partie du truc
après voilà la dubaï elle aime bien
aussi faire parler d'elle en montrant ce
qu'elle fait ça vous comprenez la
polémique non jeunes ont justement je
comprend pas la polémique
oui vraiment passé ben je comprends pas
masquer en fait elle a toujours été
comme ça elle a toujours été comme ça on
l'a toujours connu comme ça elle a
toujours voulu montrer ce qu'elle
faisait elle a toujours voulu faire plus
que les autres et moi ça me choque pas
en fait ça c'est un habile à elle elle
fait elle montre quelque chose en fait
elle donne du pain aux gens des gens
justement on est là pour elle donne du
père mais elle donne quand même une
image ya beaucoup de jeunes qui la
suivait l'écart alors que deux femmes
s'embrassent moi ça ne me choque
absolument pas ni deux hommes d'ailleurs
on est dans un pays libre et c'est très
bien mais il ya l'alcool et les choses
comme ça on est en train de se battre là
dessus chez unia juste ok beaucoup de
gens là suivait de settat je pense qu'il
ya un minimum car même à la limite a
fait son boulot elle fait ce qu'elle
veut mais là on voit la légende des gens
qui la suivent en général ils vont pas
la suivre tobey tous ici tu seras les
raisons ce sont un peu des modèles alors
caroline faut arrêter tu donnes attrait
la connerie non non tout simplement chez
moi en plus j'aime bien j'ai beaucoup
d'affection pour elle la sévère jolly
effectivement elle à cette liberté
elles sont fous de tout on peut y avoir
des polémiques sur elle sur son sac
hermès chanel ou je ne sais quoi ou dior
elle s'en fout mais sauf que la c1 c'est
un cc c'est un truc un petit peu
différent elle mais elle nous elle nous
est là n'est pas sa journée à nous
parler de son mari de son enfance machin
hume là ok n'omettant pas le droit de
péter un câble c'est pas le sud non mais
je ne le suis pas je dis juste qu
effectivement c'est un modèle
heureusement ou malheureusement j'en
sais rien mais en tout cas c'est un
modèle c'est un fait pour toute une
génération et qu'effectivement un moment
donné mais voilà ces pagnes ont brûlé
c'est pas beau alors d'accord donc est
le steack d'après c'est quoi oui c'est
quoi et puis elle convient à ce qu'elle
touche
ils ont pas besoin de la villa pour
faire des soirées des choses comme ça et
je pense que que voilà tout le monde
n'en met tout le monde autour de cette
table a fait des soirées un peu fort non
mais malgré des médias là c'est quoi des
noms mais voilà on boit on danse et il
n'y a rien de dramatique mais on est en
pleine période de covile un moment donné
vous avez des millions de gens qui vous
suivent vous donner un exemple et gèrent
pas leurs la juger mais attendez on fait
n'importe quoi c'est qui ça fait dix
minutes qu'on regarde des trucs c'est
n'importe quoi donc un moment donné
j'aurais ouais mais tu es un masque il
n'y a que ça pour moi
[Applaudissements]